[Musique]
on peut dire qu'il ya trois grands
points qui sont à surveiller l'envi de
la conférence de glace le premier
concerne le rehaussement du niveau
d'ambition notamment sur les questions
d'atténuation des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre s'il ya de plus en plus
de partis qui rehaussent leur niveau
d'ambition pour qu'on s'approche
finalement de ce que la science nous
dicte on est vraiment au dernier moment
où ce le 1.5 est encore possible on a vu
déjà différents pays qui ont mis de
l'avant des nouvelles cibles il ya 70
pays qui n'ont pas encore mis de l'avant
ces nouvelles c'est plus ambitieuse à ce
qu'on espère voir c'est peut-être le
sérieux des différents engagements
le deuxième volet concerne le
financement les pays en développement
demandent et avec raison qu'on puisse
les aider à s'adapter au changement
climatique donc en 2009 hillary clinton
au dernier moment de copenhague un peu
pour sauver les meubles avaient dit et
on va mettre 100 milliards de dollars
par année pour aider les pays en
développement dans leur lutte
aujourd'hui encore on n'a pas réussi à
mettre ce 100 milliards de dollars par
année aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
beaucoup de pays sont en train de parler
de près alors son train de dénaturer ce
qu'on avait pensé et donc ça va être
très tendu cette année à glasgow c'est
supposé d'être des dons s'est pas posé
là des prêts et quand je dis donc ce
n'est pas de la charité c'est remplir
son devoir de justice climatique et 100
milliards de dollars par année pour tous
ces pays les plus développés ensemble
c'est pas énormément c'est tout à fait
réaliste
et le dernier volet concerne une
question qui est très cher aux pays en
développement qui concerne les questions
de pertes et préjudices l'adaptation au
changement climatique est une réalité a
aussi qu'on va devoir lutter contre les
îlots de chaleur qu'on va devoir faire
face à des inondations récurrentes mais
il ya des situations où l'adaptation ne
suffit pas là où des populations perdent
leur village parce qu'ils ne sont plus à
même de faire de l'agriculture à cause
des sécheresses on assiste à la
salinisation par exemple de certaines
terres agricoles les pays en
développement veulent beaucoup qu'on
trouve des solutions concrètes pour les
aider là dedans si encore une fois les
pays riches font encore l'autruche ça va
générer des insatisfactions ferait un
grand de la part des pays les plus
vulnérables qu'ils subissent dans le
premier chef les impacts d'une crise
qu'ils iront certainement voter
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'au canada en
même temps que les changements
climatiques sont devenues un enjeu
important tu sais exactement durant la
même période que le canada a misé sur
les énergies fossiles pour son économie
comme un train qui fonce à toute allure
vers une direction et ce train là est
très difficile à arrêter justin trudeau
a hérité de ce train là ils essaient de
l'arrêter avec la taxe carbone mais en
même temps ils subventionnent encore
avec des subventions aux énergies
fossiles à chaque année alors on a plus
qu'un frein mais on donne du gaz en même
temps à ce train et et ça nous laisse
donc présager que finalement il rien qui
se passe je pense que beaucoup plus ce
qui se passe que ce faux pas juste
regarder ce qui se fait à l'échelle
fédérale parce que dans les cinq
dernières années et quand même eu des
gains notables on a une tarification
carbone le gouvernement le nouveau
gouvernement s'est engagé bien sûr à
mettre fin aux subventions aux énergies
fossiles au secteur des énergies passé
pour 2023 donc ce qui est presque demain
s'est aussi engagé à plafonner les
émissions du secteur des hydrocarbures
mais la plupart des actions elles se
font à l'échelle locale elles se font à
l'échelle des provinces le québec est
très proactif sur ces questions là
depuis de nombreuses années et je pense
qu'il faut maintenir la pression par
tous et c'est pas parce que un créneau
semble bloquée pendant un moment que les
autres ne mérite pas qu'on s'y penche
qu'on regarde tous créés etc
[Musique]
la comparaison est la suivante c'est pas
est ce que les coop on en a eu 25 et les
émissions ont pas vraiment diminué donc
les coptes sont un échec si on n'avait
pas eu les coop depuis les dernières 25
ans combien nos émissions à quel niveau
nos émissions seraient rendus
aujourd'hui c'est sûr que les coop ont
pas tout régler encore qui sont loin
d'avoir encore atteint l'objectif mais
on aurait eu un scénario beaucoup plus
qu'instable catastrophique si on n'avait
pas eu les coop depuis les derniers 25
ans d'ailleurs l'année 2022 va être une
année très important pour
l'environnement la lutte aux changements
climatiques on attend encore deux autres
volets du rapport du giec donc je pense
que ça va ébranler encore davantage les
étapes plein de choses à venir dans la
prochaine année si l'on joue un
environnement d'où vous intéresse je
vous invite à vous abonner à radio
canada environnement sur facebook et sur
instagram il divo carbone sont aussi sur
youtube sur la chaîne de radio canada
informations